A few years back, when Jada's mom took her and her sister out of the Akron, Ohio, public schools and put them into the Copley-Fairlawn public schools, Jada was just in third grade. But she noticed a difference immediately. This is Jada.
几年前，当杰达（Jada）的妈妈把她和妹妹从俄亥俄州阿克伦市的公立学校转到科普利-费尔劳恩（Copley-Fairlawn）的公立学校时，杰达才读三年级。但她立刻察觉到了不同。这就是杰达。
It was weird at first. The teachers are more serious. They really-- they buckled down. I just know that it was more educational.
起初觉得很奇怪。那里的老师更严肃。他们真的——他们非常认真。我只知道那里的教学质量更高。
Akron, where she'd been going to school before, is a city of around 200,000, and its school system recently met only five of the state's 24 educational goals. Copley-Fairlawn is just next door to Akron, has population a tenth of Akron's, and met all 24 of the goals. Even the school building, Jada says, was totally different.
阿克伦是她以前上学的城市，人口约20万，其学区最近只达到了全州24项教育目标中的5项。科普利-费尔劳恩就在阿克伦隔壁，人口只有阿克伦的十分之一，却达到了全部24项目标。杰达说，就连校舍也完全不同。
It was huge. The library was so big and had many books, and they had a greenhouse, and they had, like, a small trail in the back if you wanted to go for a walk during recess. It was amazing. They had a computer lab. It was amazing. It was so much more resources that they had there. And so we did a lot of activities outside in the greenhouse for science.
学校非常大。图书馆特别大，书很多，还有一个温室。如果你想在课间休息时散步，后面还有一条小径。太棒了。他们还有电脑室。简直太神奇了。那里的资源丰富得多。我们在温室里做了很多科学活动。
And what was science like at Akron?
那么阿克伦的科学课是什么样的呢？
It wasn't as environmental and outside, it was more of, like, in a book. So they would just say, OK, we're going to go over this chapter, and you're going to learn this.
那里没有那么多环境和户外活动，更像是……照本宣科。老师只会说：“好了，我们要看这一章，你们要学习这个。”
In Akron's science class, she says, instead of a greenhouse, each kid got a pumpkin seed and a bag.
她说，在阿克伦的科学课上，没有温室，每个孩子只得到一粒南瓜子和一个袋子。
And they put the pumpkin seed in a plastic bag, and it grew over a few months, and so we had plastic bags in shoe boxes.
他们把南瓜子放进塑料袋里，几个月下来它就发芽了，所以我们只能把塑料袋放在鞋盒子里。
After two years in this nice school, third and fourth grade, Jada was kicked out. Her sister was kicked out. To go to Copley-Fairlawn, they'd been giving their grandfather's address as their home address. Their grandfather lived in the school district.
在这所好学校上了两年（三年级和四年级）后，杰达被踢了出来。她妹妹也被踢了出来。为了进入科普利-费尔劳恩学区，她们一直用祖父的住址作为家庭住址，因为祖父住在该学区内。
Lots of districts, of course, have been cracking down on that kind of thing. Homeowners pay high property taxes to live in a place with good schools, and lots of them feel like it's wrong for anybody to freeload. So the district told Jada and her sister they had to go. Out of Copley-Fairlawn, and back to the Akron schools.
当然，许多学区一直在严厉打击这种行为。房主缴纳高额房产税以换取优质学区，他们中许多人认为任何人“蹭学”都是不对的。于是学区告诉杰达和她妹妹必须离开，必须回到阿克伦的学校。
I was a little devastated, because, like, you know, friends I made, and-- basically, like, everything about the school. I loved the school. It was, it was-- they didn't bully me there at all. The kids there were so nice and-- and then when I went to Akron Public, I was bullied because of the way I spoke, how was the grammar and different things.
我当时有点崩溃，因为，你知道，我交到的朋友，还有……基本上，关于那所学校的一切我都喜欢。我爱那所学校。在那里我一点也没被欺负。那里的孩子都很友好，但当我回到阿克伦公立学校时，我却因为说话方式、语法以及各种事情被欺负了。
And so you go back, and it's fifth grade, and it's the first day of fifth grade. Like, what do you remember from that day back, your first day back?
那你回到学校，那是五年级，五年级的第一天。你对那天有什么记忆？
I remember really just how the kids were different. And they didn't really listen to the teachers as much, and I know that it was hard to get through a lesson, because the kids were always, you know, being disruptive. And after a while being there, I knew that I wasn't really going to learn as much as I could.
我真的只记得孩子们有多么不同。他们不太听老师的话，我知道想讲完一堂课很难，因为孩子们总是在捣乱。在那里待了一段时间后，我就知道自己学不到多少东西了。
Does it seem unfair to you that your life could be so different and your school would be so different just based on where you live and what school you go to?
你会觉得仅仅因为居住地和学校不同，你的人生和教育机会就如此悬殊，这很不公平吗？
Yeah, I think that's just the dumbest thing ever. Like I just think it's-- like, how come I can't get the same education where I live than people who live three miles away from me? I don't understand, like, I just don't. I don't think it's fair that I can't learn as high quality as they can just because I'm in a different district.
是的，我认为这简直是最蠢的事情。我就是觉得……为什么我不能和我住处三英里外的人获得同样的教育？我不明白，真的不明白。我觉得仅仅因为我在不同的学区就无法获得同等高质量的教育，这太不公平了。
Of course, asking about the fairness of this is asking about something that is just built into our education system. It's the premise, right? Something that nobody's planning on changing, usually not on the table at all.
当然，质疑公平性实际上是在质疑我们教育体系中根深蒂固的东西。这就是前提，对吧？这是无人计划改变的事情，通常根本不在讨论范围内。
In America, local property taxes fund our schools. So if you live in a rich area, you get better schools. And the gaps can be huge, right? In New York State, for instance, the richest school districts, the top 10%, spend $25,000 per student, which is twice as much as the bottom 10% spends per student. And yes, there's federal money targeted to poor students, and yes, there are a tiny handful of states that have aggressively tried to shift the balance so poor kids get more because poor kids' needs are greater, but by and large, if you're living in a poor neighborhood, chances are your schools will get less money and not be as good. Neighborhood isn't destiny all the time for everybody, but for a lot of people, it comes pretty close.
在美国，地方房产税资助学校。所以如果你住在富裕地区，你就能享受到更好的学校。差距可能会非常巨大，对吧？例如在纽约州，最富有的学区（前10%）每名学生花费2.5万美元，是支出最少学区（后10%）的两倍。没错，确实有针对贫困学生的联邦资金，也确实有极少数州积极试图平衡资源，让贫困学生获得更多资助，因为他们的需求更大。但总的来说，如果你住在一个贫困社区，你的学校很可能获得的资金更少，质量也更差。社区并不总是决定一切，但对许多人来说，情况确实如此。
Today on our radio show, things did not have to end up this way. In fact, there was a moment in our history, not that long ago, where it seemed like it wouldn't end up this way. A look at how we got to this point. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass, stay with us.
今天在我们的广播节目中，事情本不一定要以这种方式结束。事实上，在不久前的历史上，曾有一个时刻看起来似乎不会这样。我们将探讨我们是如何走到这一步的。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《This American Life》，由公共广播国际（PRI）分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯，请继续收听。
Act One, Rental Gymnastics. Let's go to Nancy Updike, who has our story.
第一幕：租房体操。让我们转交给南希·厄普代克，她带来了我们的报道。
L.B. is a tall, thin man, somewhere north of 45 years old. He's soft-spoken, but he can be relentless when he's looking for an apartment. He went to one building, found the super in the hall.
L.B.是一位身材高挑瘦削的男士，45岁出头。他说话轻声细语，但在找房子时却可以锲而不舍。他去了一栋楼，在走廊里找到了管理员。
Hi.
你好。
You looking to live here?
你想住在这里吗？
Yes, I'm looking for a one-bedroom apartment for me and my wife.
是的，我在找一间一居室公寓，供我和我妻子住。
One-bedroom apartment?
一居室？
Yes, uh-huh.
是的，嗯。
Oh, I don't have.
哦，我没有。
Like, you don't have at all?
你是说完全没有吗？
No.
没有。
No?
没有吗？
No.
没有。
He told me that nothing was available.
他告诉我没有空房。
That's what the super told him. But L.B. knew that with apartment hunting, sometimes no just means you haven't asked the right question yet.
管理员就是这么对他说的。但L.B.知道，在找公寓时，有时“没有”只是意味着你还没问对人。
Is there, like, a waiting list or something that you know-- Can I put my name on a waiting list?
有没有什么候补名单之类的地方……我可以把名字写在候补名单上吗？
No, we don't have.
不，我们没有。
Oh, you don't?
哦，没有吗？
No.
没有。
There's nothing at all? My wife really likes this building.
真的什么都没有吗？我妻子真的很喜欢这栋楼。
I kept going back to the fact that my-- how much my wife likes this building, that we really want to live-- that she wants to live here, and that my wife has the final word. I always say that a lot.
我不断强调我妻子有多喜欢这栋楼，我们真的很想住在这里，她想住在这里，而且我妻子有最终决定权。我经常这么说。
You throw that one out because--
你把这一招抛出来是因为……
Yeah, I throw it out, yeah.
对，我把它抛出来，是的。
You're absolutely sure there is nothing available, because she's going to be mad at me when I get back. Listen, do you not have any one-bedrooms?
你确定真的没有空房了吗？我回去会挨妻子骂的。听着，你真的没有一居室吗？
No.
没有。
None at all?
一个都没有？
I don't have nothing.
我什么都没有。
Oh, god.
天哪。
That's the sound of a man coming to terms with his fate. But, just one last question.
这是一个男人不得不接受命运的声音。但是，最后一个问题。
Can you tell me, like, how much are the apartments going for, how much-- do you know?
你能告诉我公寓租金是多少吗？你知道吗？
$1,250.
1250美元。
$1,250? You know, well, we can afford that.
1250美元？好吧，我们付得起。
L.B. had to let it go. Except there was an apartment available, according to a later lawsuit. L.B. had been sent to the building not by his wife, but by a housing organization, as a test. L.B. is black, and the organization had also sent a white tester, Neal. Same income as L.B., also married, a little younger. He showed up at the same building, talked to the same super.
L.B.不得不放弃了。但根据后来的一场诉讼，其实是有空房的。L.B.去这栋楼不是受他妻子委托，而是一家住房组织的测试。L.B.是黑人，该组织还派了一名白人测试员尼尔（Neal）。收入和L.B.一样，也已婚，稍微年轻一点。他出现在同一栋楼，和同一个管理员谈了话。
Hello, good morning, thanks for letting me in. I'm interested in a one-bedroom for my wife and I. Do you have anything you can show me?
你好，早上好，谢谢你让我进来。我对一套给我和妻子住的一居室很感兴趣。有什么可以让我看看的吗？
Yes.
有。
Thank you, sir.
谢谢。
The super let him in, and they went up to apartment 4F.
管理员让他进去了，他们上了4F公寓。
Looks good, looks really good. Oh, this is a nice size room, huh? Very good.
看起来不错，真的很好。哦，这房间大小很合适，对吧？非常好。
When Neal asked how much the rent was, the super said $1,150. Neal wrote it down.
当尼尔问租金时，管理员说1150美元。尼尔记了下来。
OK, so tell me what's the rent?
好的，告诉我租金是多少？
$1,150.
1150美元。
One, one, five, oh.
1150。
That was $100 a month less than what the super had quoted L.B. The housing organization did another test at the same building, later, with women. An African-American woman named Kaaron went to the building.
这比管理员报给L.B.的价格每月便宜了100美元。住房组织后来在同一栋楼用女性进行了另一次测试。一位名叫卡伦（Kaaron）的非裔美国女性去了那栋楼。
I buzzed the super's apartment, and he answered, and I said, I'm looking for a one-bedroom apartment. Do you have anything available?
我按了管理员公寓的门铃，他回答了，我说：“我在找一间一居室公寓。有什么空房吗？”
Come in.
进来吧。
He buzzed me in. He let this person he could not see into his building, I went upstairs to his apartment. He opened the door.
他按了门铃让我进去。他让自己看不见的人进入了他的大楼，我上楼到了他的公寓。他打开了门。
Hi.
你好。
Hi. I was wondering  if you had any one-bedrooms or studio apartments available.
你好。我想问下你有没有一居室或单间公寓出租。
No, no, I don't have.
没有，没有，我没有。
You don't have anything?
你什么都没有？
No.
没有。
OK. Are you the super?
好的。你是管理员吗？
Yeah.
是。
When a white woman around the same age showed up, there were two studios available.
而当一位年纪相当的白人女性出现时，却有两间单间出租。
These recordings are from a lawsuit brought by an organization called the Fair Housing Justice Center. The tests were done in 2010 and 2011 in New York City.
这些录音来自一个名为“公平住房正义中心”的组织发起的诉讼。这些测试是在2010年和2011年于纽约市进行的。
Housing discrimination based on race is a lot less pervasive than it used to be, but it still happens, to a degree that surprised me when I started looking into it. It's gotten sneakier, so harder to detect, and it's not like it makes the news most of the time, so it's easy to believe it's not happening at all. The testers, like most Americans, had zero special interest in housing when they started the work. This is Laurel. She describes her test persona as a generic youngish white woman.
基于种族的住房歧视虽然比过去少得多，但依然存在，程度之深让我开始深入调查时感到惊讶。它变得更隐蔽了，难以察觉，而且大多数时候不会上新闻，所以人们很容易以为它完全不存在了。测试员们和大多数美国人一样，开始这项工作时对住房问题毫无特殊兴趣。这位是劳蕾尔（Laurel），她形容自己的测试角色是一个普通的年轻白人女性。
I mean, I was learning about the laws at the same time that I was being trained to test, and I would say part of me thought, oh, are these laws even still necessary?
我是说，我在接受测试培训的同时也在学习法律，我想我的一部分想法是：噢，这些法律还有必要吗？
So when you started, you thought, we're sort of mopping up here.
所以你刚开始时认为，我们只是在清理收尾工作。
Yeah, exactly. Like, maybe, I don't know how long this work will last, and yeah, we'll do some systemic testing throughout the city and just get the numbers that the higher-ups need. This was more census type work or something.
是的，完全正确。就像是，我不知道这项工作会持续多久，我们会在全市进行一些系统性的测试，拿到高层需要的数据。这更像是某种人口普查工作。
How is this possible? Why is this necessary? You know, we don't live in the boonies.
这怎么可能？为什么有必要这样做？要知道，我们可不是住在乡下。
This is Kaaron again. She was one of the testers at the same building L.B. went to. She said she gets a lot of questions from friends in New York about the testing. She grew up in New Orleans.
这是卡伦，她又是那位。她是L.B.去过的那栋楼的测试员之一。她说她在纽约的朋友经常问她关于测试的事。她在新奥尔良长大。
People always think of the South as this, you know, horrible place, where people are always being discriminated against, and that all the black people who have come up to the North are escaping something. You've been freed. There's like a new Underground Railroad for some reason.
人们总是认为南方是一个可怕的地方，人们总是在那里受到歧视，而所有来到北方的黑人都是在逃离某种东西。你已经自由了。出于某种原因，好像存在一条新的“地下铁路”。
But it is New York City, and there's a lot of people here, and a lot of people have a lot of different views. And I think it's easy to forget that. And some of those views are not necessarily--
但这是纽约市，这里有很多不同的人，每个人都有不同的观点。我觉得人们很容易忘记这一点。而且其中一些观点未必是……
Legal to put into action.
法律允许付诸实践的。
Yeah, that's a nice way to put it.
是的，这样说很委婉。
Kaaron's got this unsinkable vibe. She's actually an actor. The testing is only an occasional job to make some extra money. All the testers at the Fair Housing Justice Center are actors, which led me to ask them a bunch of Acting 101 questions like, do you spend a lot of time developing your character and back story before going out on a test? Do you think about your motivation? They all politely said it was a lot more straightforward than that. Show up at a place, ask what's available, just like you would if you were really looking for a home.
卡伦有一种无法被击垮的性格。她实际上是一名演员。测试只是偶尔做的一份赚外快的工作。公平住房正义中心的所有测试员都是演员，这让我问了他们很多表演课的基本问题，比如：你在去测试前会花很多时间设计角色和背景故事吗？你会考虑你的动机吗？他们都礼貌地回答，事情比那简单直接得多。去一个地方，问有什么空房，就像你真的在找房子一样。
Kaaron explained that she and the other testers are never told before they go out to a building if there's been a complaint or if it's just a random test. That's the way the Fair Housing Justice Center trained her and trains all its testers. Everyone goes out blind. No making assumptions. You're not there to trap anybody. So Kaaron went to a building in Queens one day, August, 2009, blind as usual.
卡伦解释说，他们在去大楼之前永远不会被告知是否有投诉，或者是否只是随机测试。这就是公平住房正义中心培训所有测试员的方式。每个人都是“盲测”。不做假设。你不是为了陷害任何人。所以卡伦在2009年8月的一天去了一栋皇后区的大楼，像往常一样进行盲测。
I'm like, you know, nice business casual, as if you were on a lunch. And I am small and perky, and I automatically assume that we're all going to get along very well.
我穿得比较商务休闲，就像要去吃午餐一样。我身材娇小，很有活力，我自动假设我们都会相处得很好。
She asked around the building for the super, then ran into him in the elevator.
她在楼里到处询问管理员，后来在电梯里撞见了他。
Yeah, I'm [INAUDIBLE] I'm looking for the super.
是的，我在找管理员。
I am the super.
我就是管理员。
Oh, hello.
哦，你好。
How are you?
你好吗？
I'm good. A gentleman has sent me up here. I'm looking for a one-bedroom--
我很好。有位先生让我到这儿来。我在找一间一居室……
The conversation is hard to hear over the noise of the elevator, but the super told Kaaron it was too bad, but the department had already been rented to a guy who'd been waiting for it for a long time. He sounded apologetic. It was a pleasant little chat. Kaaron thought nothing about it afterward.
因为电梯噪音，这段对话很难听清，但管理员告诉卡伦很遗憾，那间公寓已经租给了一个等待了很久的人。他听起来很抱歉。那是一次愉快的交谈。事后卡伦根本没多想。
Several months later, she heard from the Fair Housing Justice Center.
几个月后，她接到了公平住房正义中心的电话。
I get a call, and they're, like, there's been an issue with a case that you've you done. And really, when they called me, I thought it was a completely different case. I didn't realize at all.
我接到了电话，他们说，你做过的一个案子出了问题。真的，当他们给我打电话时，我以为是另一个案子。我完全没意识到。
Oh. You had someone in mind? You thought, oh, it's this one?
哦，你心里有目标了吗？你想，哦，是这一件？
Yeah.
是的。
And it wasn't that one.
结果不是那一件。
Not him at all.
根本不是他。
They told her the case was about the building where she'd talked to the super in the elevator, and Kaaron started replaying their conversation in her head. It wasn't that she couldn't believe someone might have discriminated against her in enlightened New York City, but she thought of herself as very good at reading people, how they were responding to her, and she had detected nothing.
他们告诉她，这个案子就是关于她在电梯里和管理员说话的那栋楼，卡伦开始在脑海中重演他们的对话。并不是她不相信在开明的纽约市会有人歧视她，而是她认为自己非常擅长读懂别人、了解别人的反应，而她当时什么都没察觉。
I was surprised, and I was a little-- I was like, oh, but he was so nice to me. Not-- you know, he was cordial. He wasn't throwing me a party, but he was cordial, and he wasn't rushing me out, it didn't feel like it. I was completely taken off guard.
我很惊讶，还有点……我当时想，噢，但他对我那么好。不是……你知道，他很客气。他没为我开派对，但他很客气，也没有急着赶我走，感觉不像（有歧视）。我完全措手不及。
When he told me nothing was available, I took him by face value. And I also still didn't understand exactly-- I didn't know all the other details. I hadn't been told about what had happened to the white testers. So I was still kind of like, well, maybe it wasn't as bad as I thought.
当他告诉我没有空房时，我就相信了他的话。而且我也还没完全理解细节，我不知道白人测试员身上发生了什么。所以我当时还是觉得，嗯，也许没我想的那么糟。
Hi.
你好。
Hello.
I was wondering if you had any rentals.
我想问问有没有出租的房子。
This is the recording made by Laurel, the tester who calls herself a generic youngish white woman. She'd gone to the building the same day as Kaaron, and there was an apartment for rent. It would be available in about six weeks. The super had to do some work on it to get it ready, but he was eager to get the deal settled as soon as possible, so they went to look at the apartment right then.
这是劳蕾尔制作的录音，也就是那位自称普通年轻白人女性的测试员。她和卡伦同一天去了那栋楼，当时确实有一间公寓出租。大约六周后就可以入住。管理员得做些修缮准备工作，但他很急切地想尽快定下来，所以他们当时就去看了公寓。
This is great. I guess I'll bring my husband back with me and--
这太好了。我想我会带我丈夫一起来……
You can make it sometime tonight or tomorrow, because I'm leaving for vacation tomorrow night.
你今晚或明天可以过来，因为我明晚要去度假。
Oh, OK. So any time tomorrow that's better?
哦，好的。那明天什么时候更方便？
You can come until 5:00, 5:00 in the afternoon.
你可以下午5点前过来。
To hear it, to hear the tone of voice--
听到这个，听到那个说话的语气……
This is Kaaron again.
这是卡伦。
It's jarring. It's very jarring. It was just really confusing, because while I'm listening, I'm like, well, what could I have done that would have changed? Even though-- even now, like, knowing, I'm like, oh, maybe I should have done something differently.
太刺耳了。非常刺耳。这真的非常让人困惑，因为当我听的时候，我在想，我当时做了什么能改变结果吗？即使是现在……我知道了真相，我也在想，哦，也许我应该做点不同的事情。
Is that what you were thinking when you were listening?
你听的时候是这么想的吗？
Yes. Did she push in a different way that I didn't push? Like, to see the apartment, and I was like no, she didn't actually push that hard. So I don't really-- it's hard for my brain to realize that there was nothing that I could do.
是的。她是不是用了什么我没用的方法去争取？为了看那间公寓……我说不，她其实没那么强硬地争取。所以我真的……我的大脑很难意识到我其实什么也做不了。
And for a while I had a feeling of like, well, does that mean I'm misjudging other people in my life? What does-- you know, are there other people who don't want to be near me because I'm black? What does that mean? Am I just completely misjudging the people around me?
有一段时间，我有一种感觉：这是否意味着我误判了生活中的其他人？这意味着什么……你知道，还有其他人因为我是黑人而不愿靠近我吗？这到底意味着什么？我是否完全误判了周围的人？
The lawsuit that Kaaron's recording was part of went on for almost two years, and the whole time it ate away at Kaaron.
卡伦参与的那场诉讼持续了近两年，整个过程中都在折磨着她。
Though they don't stop you from testing in the time that you're part of a case, I wasn't testing. And I think probably for the best, because I was going through a lot of doubt about-- and looking at people in a way that I'd never done before. And I questioned a lot of my judgment, my thought process, and even interactions with friends, you know, people that I've known for years. Like what, you know, how do you really think of me? What do you really think?
虽然在参与案件期间他们并不禁止你继续测试，但我没有再测试了。我想这可能是最好的，因为我经历了大量的自我怀疑，开始用一种从未有过的方式审视人们。我质疑自己的判断、思维过程，甚至与朋友、认识多年的人的互动。比如，你知道，你怎么看待我？你真正怎么想？
And it took some time before I was-- I settled myself down. It's clearly not everyone. Not everyone is like this, and you just need to get on with your life. So it was a rough, rough time.
我花了一些时间才让自己平静下来。很明显，并非每个人都这样，你必须继续你的生活。所以那是一段非常非常艰难的时期。
This is the era we've been in for a while now. If you're discriminated against in getting housing, there's a decent chance you don't know it happened. Maybe you don't even suspect it. The whole idea seems like a throwback, that a person's charm, tenacity, and income could count less than their race today when they try to rent or buy a home. And where you live can really matter.
这就是我们目前所处的时代。如果你在租房时受到歧视，很有可能你根本不知道发生了什么。也许你连怀疑都不会。整个理念看起来像是一种倒退：当一个人试图租房或买房时，他的魅力、坚韧和收入竟然比不上他的种族。而你住在哪里确实非常重要。
Every measure of well-being and opportunity, the foundation is where you live.
在衡量幸福和机会的每一个标准中，基础都是你住在哪里。
This is Nikole Hannah-Jones. She's a reporter for ProPublica, and she's written a lot about housing and the way it can affect every part of a person's life, the quality of schools, and hospitals, also--
这位是妮可·汉娜-琼斯（Nikole Hannah-Jones）。她是ProPublica的一名记者，写了很多关于住房及其如何影响一个人生活方方面面的文章，比如学校和医院的质量……
Cancer rates, asthma rates, infant mortality, unemployment, education, access to fresh food, access to parks, whether or not the city repairs the roads in your neighborhood.
癌症发病率、哮喘发病率、婴儿死亡率、失业率、教育、获得新鲜食物的机会、公园的使用权，以及城市是否修理你所在社区的道路。
Besides that, there's also this. Black and white Americans still live substantially apart in this country. It's especially true in cities like Chicago and New York that have large African-American populations. Overall, the United States is vastly less segregated than it was 45 years ago. We're a different country. There are almost no all white neighborhoods anymore.
除此之外，还有这个。黑人和白人美国人在这个国家依然基本上是分开生活的。在芝加哥和纽约这样拥有大量非裔美国人的城市尤其如此。总的来说，美国现在的种族隔离程度比45年前要低得多。我们是一个不同的国家了。几乎不再有全白人社区了。
But there are plenty that are almost all black. In hundreds of metropolitan areas, the average white person lives in a neighborhood that's 75% white, and their neighbors who aren't white aren't likely to be African American. That's according to a study by sociologists at Brown and Florida State universities, based on the 2010 census.
但仍有许多社区几乎全都是黑人。根据布朗大学和佛罗里达州立大学社会学家基于2010年人口普查的一项研究，在数百个大都市区，平均一个白人居住的社区中75%是白人，而他们的非白人邻居也不太可能是非裔美国人。
The most segregated parts of the country are, and have been for decades, the Northeast and the Midwest. Milwaukee is consistently one of the most segregated cities in the country. In Milwaukee and in other cities, including New York, the level of black-white segregation by one important measure has declined only by a trickle in 30 years.
全国种族隔离最严重的地区几十年来一直是东北部和中西部。密尔沃基始终是全国种族隔离最严重的城市之一。在密尔沃基和其他城市，包括纽约，按照一项重要指标衡量，黑人与白人的种族隔离水平在30年内仅出现了微小的下降。
I've got a map on the wall in my office of Brooklyn that shows a giant red cluster right in the middle, where African Americans make up over 80% of the population, even though they're only 25% of the city overall, and even though on the street, New York feels like a very integrated city. This is Nikole Hannah-Jones again. She lives in New York.
我的办公室墙上有一张布鲁克林地图，中间有一个巨大的红色集群，非裔美国人占了人口的80%以上，尽管他们在全市总体人口中只占25%，尽管在街上走的时候，纽约感觉是一个非常融合的城市。这就是妮可·汉娜-琼斯。她住在纽约。
I think a good way to visualize it in the city is when you ride the subway or the bus. When you get on at certain parts, the bus is very integrated. And then as you go to certain neighborhoods, all the white people get off, and then it's only black people left on the bus.
我认为在城市里观察它的一个好方法是乘坐地铁或公交车。当你在某些地方上车时，公交车非常融合。然后当你去往某些社区时，所有白人都下车了，剩下的车上只有黑人。
How much of the current level of segregation in New York and other cities is due to discrimination, compared to other factors like poverty, that's being studied and debated. I'll get to that later in the show. But what's clear is that as the country has become less segregated overall, there are still large stubborn pockets of racial and economic segregation in major US cities. And that's true nearly half a century after we passed a critical piece of civil rights legislation, the Fair Housing Act.
纽约和其他城市目前的种族隔离水平，有多少是由于歧视造成的，与贫困等其他因素相比如何？这正在被研究和辩论。我稍后会在节目中谈到。但显而易见的是，尽管国家总体上的种族隔离程度降低了，但在美国主要城市中，仍然存在着大块顽固的种族和经济隔离区。而在我们通过一项关键民权立法——《公平住房法》近半个世纪后，情况依然如此。
It's been 45 years since we declared as a country that housing discrimination was a problem and we needed to solve it. When the law was passed, it talked big. It not only banned discrimination in the sale or rental of housing based on race and a bunch of other categories. The first line of the law says, quote, "It is the policy of the United States to provide, within constitutional limitations, for fair housing throughout the United States." Big.
自从我们国家宣布住房歧视是一个我们需要解决的问题以来，已经过去45年了。法案通过时，口气很大。它不仅禁止在住房销售或租赁中基于种族和其他类别的歧视。法案的第一行写着，引用：“美利坚合众国的政策是，在宪法限制范围内，在全美范围内提供公平住房。”口气很大。
Of course, laws are often big talkers, and it's a lot easier to talk big than to make effective policy. With housing, with lots of issues. But everything that went into creating the Fair Housing Act is worth looking at today, 45 years later-- standard middle aged moment to look back-- to try to understand where we are and aren't today.
当然，法律往往只是“口头巨人”，制定有效的政策远比大放厥词要难得多。住房问题如此，许多问题也如此。但创造《公平住房法》的一切过程，在45年后的今天都值得审视——这是中年回顾的时刻——以试着理解我们现在处于何处，以及我们未能达到何处。
Nikole Hannah-Jones, the reporter for ProPublica, spent a year and a half digging into the Fair Housing Act. Really digging, going to presidential archives, talking to people in government now and from the time the law was passed, looking at demographic data, and at policies going back 80 years, and what she found was that the story really started back when the biggest housing discriminator in the country was the federal government.
ProPublica的记者妮可·汉娜-琼斯花了整整一年半的时间挖掘《公平住房法》。真正的挖掘，查阅总统档案馆，采访现在和法案通过时期的政府人员，查看人口数据和过去80年的政策，她发现这个故事实际上始于全国最大的住房歧视者就是联邦政府的时候。
It really started after the Great Depression. So in the early to mid '30s, the federal government realized that home ownership was going to be a major way to build and fortify the middle class. So the Roosevelt administration starts to back loans. And so you only had to put down 20%. And this is when the practice of redlining actually began. The federal government was the one who introduced redlining.
它真的始于大萧条之后。所以在大萧条中期，联邦政府意识到房屋所有权将是建立和巩固中产阶级的主要途径。于是罗斯福政府开始支持贷款。你只需要首付20%。这就是“红线区划”（Redlining）做法真正开始的时候。引入“红线区划”的正是联邦政府。
Redlining is now pretty well known, and the word has become a catch-all for various maneuvers that banks and others have used to deny loans or services based on race. But most people may not know-- I didn't know-- that it wasn't banks that popularized redlining. It was the federal government under President Franklin Roosevelt, a Democrat, that drew red lines on maps around certain neighborhoods and refused to back home loans there. There were other designations on the maps, by the way, for areas with Jews and others, anyone who was perceived as risky. Banks followed the government's lead in terms of lending, and so did big government programs that came out later, like the GI bill.
“红线区划”现在已经广为人知，这个词已成为银行和其他机构用来拒绝基于种族提供贷款或服务的各种手段的总称。但大多数人可能不知道——我以前也不知道——普及红线区划的并不是银行。而是富兰克林·罗斯福总统（一位民主党人）领导下的联邦政府，他们在地图上划出某些社区的红线，并拒绝为那里的房屋贷款背书。顺便说一句，地图上还有针对犹太人和其他人的其他标记，任何人被认为有风险都会被标出。银行在贷款方面紧随政府的引导，后来推出的重大政府项目（如《退伍军人权利法案》）也是如此。
It was not just about whether a neighborhood was black or not, but whether that neighborhood was integrated, and the government wanted to provide a disincentive to live in an integrated neighborhood. So if you were a white homeowner who didn't mind living in an integrated neighborhood, you could not get a loan. And if you owned a home in an integrated neighborhood, you knew that you could not resell your home to other white folks, so you had to sell your home to black people and get the hell-- oops, excuse me-- get the heck out of there. Because your property values were absolutely going to go down. It had nothing to do with whether the black people in your neighborhood could afford to pay their mortgage, or whether--
这不仅关乎一个社区是否是黑人社区，还关乎该社区是否是混合居住的，政府想提供一种不去混合社区居住的抑制因素。所以，如果你是一个不介意住在混合社区的白人房主，你就无法获得贷款。如果你拥有混合社区的一套房子，你知道你不能把房子卖给其他白人，所以你必须把房子卖给黑人，然后……噢，抱歉，赶紧逃离那里。因为你的房产价值绝对会下降。这与社区里的黑人是否付得起抵押贷款无关，也与……
They mowed their lawns, or--
他们是否除草，或者……
Right, exactly, not keeping their properties up. It was about the fact that the government was deeming these neighborhoods as less valuable. And so your property values were going to go down because the government had decided that black and integrated neighborhoods were automatically less valuable.
是的，没错，是否保持房产状况良好。这是因为政府认为这些社区价值较低。所以你的房产价值会下降，因为政府已经决定，黑人和混合居住的社区自动价值较低。
The federal government's redlining drove white flight, and the government did not see this as a problem. Open racism was mainstream in the 1930s, including in the federal government. A manual put out by the Federal Housing Administration warned against undesirable encroachment of inharmonious racial groups.
联邦政府的“红线区划”推动了白人的外迁，而政府并不认为这是个问题。公开的种族主义在20世纪30年代是主流，在联邦政府内部也是如此。联邦住房管理局发布的一本手册警告不要出现“不协调的种族群体的不良入侵”。
And federal attitudes and policies amplified what was already happening at the local level. There was flat out violence in some places, first of all, against blacks trying to move into white neighborhoods. There were also racial zoning laws, something called racial covenants. These were contracts attached to properties that said things like "At no time shall said premises be sold, occupied, let, or leased to anyone of any race other than the Caucasian." But discriminatory policies by the federal government had more reach than any local policy.
联邦政府的态度和政策放大了地方层面已经发生的事情。首先，在某些地方确实存在针对试图搬入白人社区的黑人的暴力行为。还有种族分区法，即所谓的“种族契约”。这些是附在房产上的合同，上面写着类似“在任何时候，上述房产不得出售、占用、出租或租赁给高加索人以外的任何种族的人”。但联邦政府的歧视性政策比任何地方政策的影响力都大。
And what ultimately happens, of course, between 1934 and 1964, 98% of the home loans that are insured by the federal government go to white Americans, building up the white middle class by allowing them to get home ownership. And black Americans are largely left out of that process. And, if there's one thing that's amazing about all of this, is how efficient the federal government was in creating segregation.
最终发生的事情当然是，在1934年至1964年间，联邦政府担保的98%的房屋贷款都流向了白人美国人，通过让他们获得房屋所有权建立了白人中产阶级。而美国黑人基本上被排除在这个过程之外。而且，如果说关于这一切有什么令人惊叹的地方，那就是联邦政府在制造种族隔离方面的效率之高。
Around 1930, most black Americans in Northern cities are living in neighborhoods that are about 30% black. By the '60s, the neighborhoods of African Americans in the industrial Northeast are 74% percent black and higher.
1930年左右，北方城市的大多数美国黑人生活在约30%是黑人的社区中。到了60年代，工业化东北部地区非裔美国人的社区中，黑人比例达到74%以上。
No other racial or ethnic group has ever been that segregated. Even when you had large groups of immigrants coming from Ireland or Poland or Italy, even in places where they had Little Italys and things like that. So by 1960, cities have largely been abandoned by white Americans, you have massive public housing projects, where nearly everyone in there is black and poor, and even if you're middle class and black, you can't move out of those neighborhoods. You're still forced to live in those very dead neighborhoods.
从来没有任何其他种族或族裔群体受到过如此严重的隔离。即使在有大量来自爱尔兰、波兰或意大利的移民团体时，即使在他们有“小意大利”之类的地方时也是如此。因此，到1960年，城市在很大程度上被白人美国人抛弃了，你有了大规模的公共住房项目，那里几乎每个人都是黑人和穷人；即使你是中产阶级黑人，你也无法搬出那些社区。你仍然被迫生活在那些非常死气沉沉的社区里。
By 1967, President Lyndon Johnson had already signed into law two civil rights bills, but he couldn't get much traction on a housing law. So he flattered a new young senator, Walter Mondale, into helping lead the push for a housing bill in the Senate.
到1967年，林登·约翰逊总统已经签署了两项民权法案，但他无法在住房法案上取得太大进展。于是他奉承一位年轻的新参议员沃尔特·蒙代尔（Walter Mondale），让他帮助领导参议院推动住房法案。
Now Walter Mondale was picked because everyone else had turned Lyndon B. Johnson down.
沃尔特·蒙代尔之所以被选中，是因为其他所有人都拒绝了林登·B·约翰逊。
Everyone else was too smart to take it on.
其他人都太聪明了，没接这个烫手山芋。
Exactly. Housing was toxic. All of the other civil rights laws, they were kind of designed to shake their fingers at the recalcitrant South and make the South behave.
没错。住房问题太有毒了。其他所有的民权法案，其设计初衷都是为了对冥顽不化的南方摇手指，让南方表现得规矩点。
And that's exactly what Mondale told you.
这正是蒙代尔告诉你的。
That's right. The housing bill was considered the first Northern civil rights bill. It was easy for Northern liberals to support the '65 Voting Rights Act and the 1964 Civil Rights Act, but they balked.
没错。住房法案被认为是第一部北方民权法案。北方自由派很容易支持1965年的《投票权法案》和1964年的《民权法案》，但这次他们退缩了。
Mondale told Nikole that when he brought up a housing bill, some liberal Northern senators told him--
蒙代尔告诉妮可，当他提出住房法案时，一些自由派北方参议员告诉他……
You're embarrassing us with this. You're making us look like hypocrites by introducing this bill, and we can't support it.
“你因为这个让我们感到尴尬。你提出这个法案让我们看起来像伪君子，我们没法支持。”
By exposing our hypocrisy, you're making us look like hypocrites.
通过暴露我们的虚伪，你让我们看起来像伪君子。
That's exactly right.
正是这样。
The idea that housing was a Northern problem as well as a Southern one was also made clear when Reverend Martin Luther King went to Chicago to push for what he called open-housing.
住房既是北方问题也是南方问题，这一点在马丁·路德·金牧师前往芝加哥推动他所谓的“开放住房”运动时也变得明朗。
When he started moving his movement northward to address housing segregation, that's when he began to lose a lot of support. The white liberals who had supported his campaign in the South began to abandon him. When he was marching for housing integration in Chicago, an angry mob hit him in the head with a rock.
当他开始将运动转向北方以解决住房隔离问题时，他开始失去大量支持。那些在南方支持他运动的白人自由派开始抛弃他。当他在芝加哥为住房融合游行时，暴徒用石头击中了他的头部。
More and more Americans were finding blatant racial discrimination to be gross and unacceptable, but that didn't mean they were prepared for their own lives to change. What Mondale figured out was that the Senate version of that disconnect, if he leveraged it right, might work in the Fair Housing Bill's favor.
越来越多的美国人开始认为赤裸裸的种族歧视是令人作呕且不可接受的，但这并不意味着他们准备好让自己的生活发生改变。蒙代尔发现，参议院对这种脱节的处理方式，如果他能善加利用，也许对公平住房法案有利。
He starts to gather testimony from veterans, African Americans who had fought in Vietnam and who were serving in the military, and the trouble that they were having after coming back from fighting for this country, and then coming home and not being able to find housing because of their race. And one of the testimony that really started to change minds was Carlos Campbell.
他开始收集退伍军人的证词，那些曾在越南作战并服役的非裔美国人，他们在为这个国家战斗后回来，却因为种族原因找不到住房，面临着困境。其中一个真正开始改变人们想法的证词来自卡洛斯·坎贝尔（Carlos Campbell）。
There's no recording of Campbell's testimony, but it's in the written record. He was a lieutenant in the Navy, a navigator, who'd been serving for eight years and was still on active duty when he was assigned to the Defense Intelligence Agency in Arlington, Virginia. He said he spent weeks going to more than 30 apartments in the area, wearing his uniform, which he described as complete with gold stripes and gold wings.
没有坎贝尔证词的录音，但有书面记录。他是海军少校，一名导航员，已经服役八年，在被分配到弗吉尼亚州阿灵顿的国防情报局时仍处于现役。他说，他身穿制服（他描述为配有金色条纹和金色翅膀），花了数周时间去了该地区30多处公寓。
Some places told him flat out, "we aren't integrated." Others turned him away by saying that they had an exceptionally long waiting list, or that it would take at least four weeks to process a routine application. Finally, the only way that Campbell-- a military officer who had been hired by the Pentagon-- the only way that he was able to find a place for his family to live was by renting the home of a fellow military officer who was being posted elsewhere for a couple of years.
有些地方直截了当地告诉他：“我们这里不混合居住。”另一些人则通过说他们有特别长的候补名单，或者处理常规申请至少需要四周时间来拒绝他。最终，坎贝尔——一名被五角大楼雇佣的军官——唯一能为家人找到住所的方法，是租下另一位被调往别处的军官的家。
Campbell's testimony started changing some Senator's minds, even some outright segregationists. Campbell had fought for his country but was being turned away from housing for his family. It seemed un-American. But still the bill didn't pass, and the country was in the midst of massive upheaval.
坎贝尔的证词开始改变一些参议员的想法，甚至是彻底的种族隔离主义者。坎贝尔为国家而战，却被拒绝为家人提供住所。这看起来很不“美国”。但法案仍未通过，国家正处于巨大的动荡之中。
Starting from '65 until '68, there were riots in black communities in more than 100 cities across the nation.
从65年到68年，全国100多个城市的黑人社区发生了骚乱。
[GUNFIRE]
[枪声]
This is Newark, New Jersey in 1967. Some of you probably lived through the riots in your cities, but for those who didn't, this video from Newark looks like scenes from a foreign war, where the military is fighting in the streets of a city. Truckloads of men in military uniforms are driving through. And riots were happening in cities all over the country. Los Angeles, Chicago, Cleveland, San Francisco, Tampa, Buffalo, Atlanta, Boston, Omaha, Waukegan, Detroit, Durham, Memphis, Milwaukee, Minneapolis.
这是1967年的新泽西州纽瓦克。你们中有些人可能经历过自己城市的骚乱，但对于那些没经历过的人来说，这段来自纽瓦克的视频看起来像是外国战争的场景，军队在城市街道上作战。装满军人的卡车穿行而过。全国各地的城市都在发生骚乱。洛杉矶、芝加哥、克利夫兰、旧金山、坦帕、布法罗、亚特兰大、波士顿、沃基根、底特律、达勒姆、孟菲斯、密尔沃基、明尼阿波利斯。
I can't imagine this happening in dozens of cities every year for three years. Tanks rolling through American cities. You have combat troops in American cities. Buildings on fire.
我无法想象三年里每年在几十个城市发生这种事。坦克在美国家园里穿行。美国城市里有作战部队。大楼着火。
President Johnson appointed a commission known as the Kerner Commission, Republicans and Democrats, to look into the riots, which were freaking out the entire country-- no surprise. In debates, some members of Congress argued that civil rights legislation, including a housing law, would reward and encourage rioting. The Kerner Commission's report came out while Congress was debating a fair housing bill for the third time, after it had failed to pass twice before.
约翰逊总统任命了一个被称为“克纳委员会”（Kerner Commission）的委员会，由共和党人和民主党人组成，专门调查当时令全国恐慌的骚乱——这并不奇怪。在辩论中，一些国会议员辩称，民权立法（包括住房法）会奖励和鼓励骚乱。克纳委员会的报告是在国会第三次辩论公平住房法案时发布的，之前该法案已经两次未获通过。
The report was published as a paperback book-- I'm looking down at a copy right now-- and it's got three questions emblazoned on the front. These are the questions President Johnson had publicly asked the commission to address. What happened? Why did it happen? What can be done?
该报告作为平装书出版——我手里正拿着一本——封面上有三个显眼的问题。这些是约翰逊总统公开要求委员会解决的问题：发生了什么？为什么发生？能做什么？
It sold something like two million copies when it first came out, so Americans were actually really interested--
它刚出版时销量大约有200万册，所以美国人实际上对这份报告非常感兴趣……
That's a bestseller.
那是畅销书。
--in this report. It was definitely a bestseller, and back then it was certainly a bestseller. But you have to understand, there had been four years of rioting in cities all across the country. And so I think many Americans were anxious to read an assessment of why this was.
——肯定是一本畅销书，在当时绝对是。但你必须理解，全国各地的城市已经发生了四年的骚乱。所以我认为许多美国人都渴望阅读关于骚乱原因的评估。
The report is more than 600 pages, but its conclusion was simple, and has been famously and repeatedly quoted since. Quote, "Our nation is moving toward two societies, one black and one white, separate and unequal." The commissioners had spent months going to the cities, looking at data, interviewing people, residents, police, politicians, and they concluded that there was one central driving force behind the riots. This is Nikole quoting from the book. She's got her own copy.
报告有600多页，但结论很简单，自发布以来一直被反复引用。引用：“我们的国家正在走向两个社会，一个是黑人社会，一个是白人社会，分离且不平等。”委员们花了几个月时间走访城市，查看数据，采访居民、警察、政治家，他们得出结论，骚乱背后有一个核心驱动力。这是妮可引用书中的话。她拿着自己的副本。
"Segregation and poverty have created, in the racial ghetto, a destructive environment totally unknown to most white Americans. What white Americans have never fully understood, but what the Negro can never forget, is that white society is deeply implicated in the ghetto. White institutions created it, white institutions maintain it, and white society condones it."
“种族隔离和贫困在种族隔离区内创造了一种大多数白人美国人完全不知道的破坏性环境。白人美国人从未完全理解，但黑人永远不会忘记的是，白人社会与隔离区有极深的牵连。白人制度创造了它，白人制度维持着它，白人社会纵容着它。”
So I think people tend to think that generally people live like they do. And I think that they took great pains to say, we went into these communities--
所以我认为人们倾向于认为每个人生活状况大致相同。而且我认为他们极力强调说：我们走进这些社区……
We the commission.
我们委员会。
Exactly, we the Kerner commission. We're like you. You know, we're a largely white male group, and we went into those communities, and--
没错，我们克纳委员会。我们就像你们。你知道，我们主要是一群白人男性，我们走进那些社区，并且……
They're not living like us.
他们生活得不像我们。
--we found something-- yeah-- that we did not imagine.
——我们发现了一些……是的……我们没有想象到的事情。
My fellow citizens, Detroit and much of Michigan have just lived through seven days of terror and trouble and tension.
我的同胞们，底特律和密歇根州的大部分地区刚刚经历了七天的恐怖、麻烦和紧张。
This is the governor of Michigan at the time, George Romney, Mitt Romney's father. George Romney was about to become a huge player in the story of the Fair Housing Act. His state had been hit with one of the worst riots in US history, Detroit in 1967. Romney called in the National Guard, President Johnson sent in army troops, 43 people died, over 1,000 injured, tens of millions of dollars worth of damage. Governor Romney was planning to run for president in the coming year, and he gave a live televised speech to the people of Michigan in the aftermath of the Detroit riots.
这是当时的密歇根州州长乔治·罗姆尼（George Romney），米特·罗姆尼（Mitt Romney）的父亲。乔治·罗姆尼即将成为《公平住房法》故事中的关键人物。他的州遭受了美国历史上最严重的骚乱之一，即1967年的底特律。罗姆尼召集了国民警卫队，约翰逊总统派出了陆军部队，43人死亡，1000多人受伤，造成数千万美元的损失。罗姆尼州长计划在接下来的一年竞选总统，他在底特律骚乱后的余波中向密歇根州人民发表了电视直播演说。
Some white people and public officials advocate the return to states' rights as a way to legalize segregation of the races. White extremist organizations are preaching hate and arming. More and more Negroes are listening to and supporting Negro leaders who advocate a separate black society in America. These militant revolutionists are preaching hate, violence, and rebellion.
一些白人和公职人员主张回归“州权”，以此作为合法化种族隔离的手段。白人极端主义组织正在宣扬仇恨并武装自己。越来越多的黑人正在倾听和支持主张在美国建立一个单独的黑人社会的黑人领袖。这些激进革命者正在宣扬仇恨、暴力和叛乱。
Romney believed the country was in danger of splintering, and he laid out a whole plan in his speech to fight that. He wanted tough law enforcement, moral and religious renewal, both very popular ideas. But he also declared that, while others were calling for more separation between blacks and whites in response to the riots, he, Romney, was going to lead Michigan in the opposite direction with a special focus on housing. And he didn't just throw in a token sentence about it.
罗姆尼认为国家面临分裂的危险，他在演讲中提出了一个完整的计划来对抗这种局面。他想要强有力的法律执行、道德和宗教更新，这些都是非常受欢迎的观点。但他还宣布，尽管其他人呼吁通过进一步隔离黑人和白人来应对骚乱，但他——罗姆尼——将领导密歇根州朝着相反的方向前进，特别关注住房问题。而且他不仅仅是在其中加了一句客套话。
We must have open housing on a statewide basis. Zoning that creates either large-scale economic or racial segregation should be eliminated. We must provide low cost private housing through nonprofit organizations in all parts of the metropolitan area and throughout the state. We must compel real estate agents to--
我们必须在全州范围内实行开放住房。应消除造成大规模经济或种族隔离的分区制度。我们必须通过非营利组织在整个大都市区和全州范围内提供低成本的私人住房。我们必须强迫房地产经纪人……
I was reading through Romney's papers, and he was getting all of these letters from angry white citizens--
我查阅了罗姆尼的文件，他收到了所有这些来自愤怒的白人公民的信件……
After the riots.
骚乱之后。
--after the riots, who were on the one hand commending him for his law and order approach-- they called in the National Guard, there were actually, again, army combat troops were brought to quell it-- and they really were applauding him for his use of force in quelling the riots. Some of them wanting him to go even further, some of the letters being very openly racist, and his response to them I found to be remarkable. Most politicians, I think, would've played into that for popularity.
——骚乱之后。他们一方面称赞他的法律与秩序方针——他召集了国民警卫队，实际上再次重申，陆军作战部队被带进来平定骚乱——他们确实非常赞赏他使用武力平息骚乱。有些人希望他走得更远，有些信件公然表达种族主义，但我发现他对这些信件的反应非常值得注意。我想大多数政治家为了受欢迎会迎合那种情绪。
Thank you for your support.
谢谢你的支持。
Exactly. I'll do it again if I have to. But his answer to them was, yes, I had to, we will not accept lawlessness, but at the same time we can't just look away from what's caused this. And he believed that housing segregation and the conditions created by the ghetto were what led to the riots, and that it was his duty to address those. And--
正是。如果有必要我会再做一次。但他对他们的回答是：是的，我不得不这样做，我们不会接受无法无天，但同时我们不能仅仅对造成这一切的原因视而不见。他认为住房隔离和贫民窟造成的环境是导致骚乱的原因，处理这些问题是他的职责。而且……
He wrote--
他写道……
He wrote that in letters, over and over.
他反复在信中这样写。
George Romney was way out ahead of the federal government here. The Fair Housing Act had failed to pass Congress in 1966, failed again in 1967, even though it was gaining votes. In 1968, the Kerner Commission report came out, but still the bill was expected to fail a third time, until Reverend Martin Luther King was assassinated. A week later, the Fair Housing Act passed, and the fight to implement it began.
乔治·罗姆尼在这一点上远远领先于联邦政府。《公平住房法》曾于1966年未获国会通过，1967年再次失败，尽管当时支持票数正在增加。1968年，克纳委员会报告发布，但预计法案第三次仍会失败，直到马丁·路德·金牧师遇刺。一周后，《公平住房法》通过，实施它的斗争开始了。
Nancy Updike. Coming up, George Romney versus the President of the United States. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
南希·厄普代克。接下来是乔治·罗姆尼与美国总统的较量。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, House Rules. If neighborhood is destiny, or something like that, how we have ended up in the neighborhoods that we're in. We're devoting our whole show today to the story of the law that ordered the federal government to proactively integrate housing in this country, and what happened after it was passed.
这里是《This American Life》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《房屋守则》。如果社区就是命运，或者类似的东西，那么我们是如何走到我们所处的这些社区的。我们今天整档节目都在讲述那部下令联邦政府积极促进国内住房融合的法律的故事，以及它通过之后发生的事情。
Nancy Updike tells our story this hour. A lot of that story is based on research done by Nikole Hannah-Jones, from the investigative reporting organization ProPublica. She's been researching this history for a special project on fair housing laws that's on ProPublica's homepage right now.
南希·厄普代克在这一小时讲述我们的故事。这个故事很多是基于调查性报道组织ProPublica的记者妮可·汉娜-琼斯的研究所得。她一直在为ProPublica主页上关于公平住房法的专题项目研究这段历史。
We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Missionary. So Nancy now picks up our story where we left off, 1968, when the Fair Housing Act was signed into law.
我们现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕：《传教士》。现在南希从我们之前中断的地方捡起故事：1968年，《公平住房法》被签署成为法律。
The next president after the Fair Housing Act passed was Richard Nixon, and to head the department that was going to oversee the new law he appointed George Romney, former governor of Michigan, former businessman, recent author of a book called The Concerns of a Citizen . In the book, there's a speech he gave that starts, "I have just returned from a tour across America. It was the kind of tour that few Americans have taken and few would care to take. I saw the America of ugly streets and rotten buildings. The America of congestion, illiteracy, and want. The America of shattered expectations and rising fury." He gave that speech months before the Kerner Commission report came out.
《公平住房法》通过后的下一任总统是理查德·尼克松，为了领导监督这项新法律的部门，他任命了乔治·罗姆尼，前密歇根州州长，前商人，最近还写了一本名为《公民的担忧》（The Concerns of a Citizen）的书。书中有一段他发表的演讲，开头写道：“我刚从一次横跨美国的巡回访问中回来。那是极少数美国人走过、极少数人愿意走的巡回访问。我看到了肮脏街道和破烂建筑的美国。拥挤、文盲和匮乏的美国。期望破碎和愤怒日益增长的美国。”他在克纳委员会报告发布前几个月就发表了那次演讲。
George Romney was of the Republican Party's more liberal Northern wing.
乔治·罗姆尼属于共和党内较温和的北方派。
Again, this is Nikole Hannah-Jones, the reporter from ProPublica.
再次说明，这是ProPublica的记者妮可·汉娜-琼斯。
And he actually ran against Nixon in the presidential election, and part of his undoing was his outspokenness on the issue of race. He actually said that the white suburbs had created a noose around the black inner cities, which is pretty strong language evoking lynching, but that's what he believed was happening.
他实际上在总统大选中与尼克松竞争，他垮台的部分原因是在种族问题上的直言不讳。他实际上说白人郊区在黑人中心城市周围制造了一个“绞索”，这是非常强烈的、让人联想到私刑的措辞，但这正是他认为正在发生的事情。
Why did Nixon pick Romney to lead housing? He definitely wasn't a political soul mate. But Romney made sense. He was a high profile Republican who was credible on housing issues because of his stand in Michigan.
为什么尼克松选择罗姆尼来领导住房部门？他绝对不是政治上的灵魂伴侣。但罗姆尼有道理。他是一位高调的共和党人，因为他在密歇根州的立场而在住房问题上具有公信力。
So Romney's new job was Secretary of HUD, the Department of Housing and Urban Development. And this was a job for a confident man, because here's HUD in 1968. It's a newly formed department-- had been created only three years before-- and it was administering programs that, until recently, had explicitly discriminated based on race, running public housing that was either only for whites or only for blacks, denying loans in integrated areas, now charged with doing the exact opposite, enforcing the brand new fair housing law. And for enforcement, Romney was left mainly with a vague section of the law that instructed HUD to--
所以罗姆尼的新工作是住房和城市发展部（HUD）部长。这是一个自信的人才能胜任的工作，因为这就是1968年的HUD。这是一个新成立的部门——三年前才刚成立——它管理的这些项目直到最近还在明确地基于种族进行歧视，运营着要么只对白人、要么只对黑人开放的公共住房，在混合居住区拒绝贷款，现在却被要求做完全相反的事情：执行全新的公平住房法。而在执法方面，罗姆尼主要只剩下法律中模糊不清的一节，指示HUD要……
"Affirmatively further" the provisions of the law, so--
“积极进一步”推进法律条款，所以……
And those are the words in the law, "affirmatively further."
这就是法律中的字面意思，“积极进一步”。
Yes. It wasn't just that the government had to stop discriminating and enforce the law, but the law was written to say, you actually have to take proactive steps to dismantle the segregation that you helped create.
是的。政府不仅要停止歧视并执行法律，法律的初衷是说：你实际上必须采取主动措施，拆除你曾帮助建立的种族隔离。
The question was how to do it. Here's how Romney went about trying to fulfill that mandate to affirmatively further fair housing.
问题是如何做到这一点。下面就是罗姆尼为履行“积极进一步”推进公平住房的职责所尝试的方法。
He realizes-- so the US Department of Housing and Urban Development was giving billions of dollars in grants for sewers and highways, and to build housing in communities all across the country, and Romney decides that that is a good choke point. That if communities are going to be taking federal dollars, particularly federal housing dollars, they better be willing to open themselves up to people of different races, particularly African Americans at that time. But he also knows that this is not something that Nixon is going to be happy with.
他意识到——美国住房和城市发展部向全国各地的社区发放了数十亿美元的下水道和高速公路建设补助金，以及住房建设资金，罗姆尼认为这是一个很好的控制点。如果社区打算接受联邦资金，特别是联邦住房资金，他们最好愿意向不同种族的人开放，特别是当时的非裔美国人。但他也知道尼克松对此不会高兴。
President Nixon was complicated on civil rights, like he was on everything. His administration worked to build up minority-owned businesses. They made efforts to desegregate schools. But when it came to housing, Nixon was vehemently against what he called forced integration. So opposed that for a while he was bent on pushing a constitutional amendment to ban it.
尼克松总统在民权问题上的态度和他在所有事情上一样复杂。他的政府致力于建立少数族裔拥有的企业。他们努力推动学校种族融合。但当谈到住房时，尼克松坚决反对他所谓的“强制融合”。反对程度之深，以至于有一段时间他一心想推动一项宪法修正案来禁止它。
Of course, Romney would say it's voluntary integration because you don't have to take these federal dollars, and if you don't want the money, then do what you want.
当然，罗姆尼会说这是“自愿融合”，因为你不必接受这些联邦资金，如果你不想要钱，那就做你想做的事。
We're just not going to pay for it.
我们只是不给钱。
Right.
没错。
Romney had the backbone and the bullheadedness of a true believer. He thought housing segregation was a central part of, quote, "the greatest crisis in our nation's history." He didn't have the patience for building momentum or trying to sway Nixon.
罗姆尼拥有真正信仰者的骨气和固执。他认为住房隔离是“我们国家历史上最严重的危机”的核心组成部分。他没有耐心去建立势头或试图左右尼克松。
So Romney's archives have all of these letters going back and forth between Romney and his advisers, and his advisers writing each other, putting together their plan to affirmatively further the Fair Housing Act.
所以罗姆尼的档案馆里有所有这些罗姆尼和顾问之间来往的信件，顾问们互相写信，制定他们推进《公平住房法》的计划。
And they're trying to figure out, OK, how do we do this without letting Nixon know. And so they have all these strategies-- we can just tell him, but if we tell him, he'll stop it. Or we can maybe let him know a little bit. Or do we just completely launch it under the radar and then let him know at some later point.
他们试图弄清楚，好，我们如何在不让尼克松知道的情况下做到这一点。于是他们有了各种策略——我们可以直接告诉他，但如果我们告诉他，他会阻止我们。或者我们可以让他知道一点点。或者我们干脆完全私下启动它，然后再在以后的某个时间点告诉他。
And that's ultimately what they decide to do. They decide that they're just going to start this project called Open Communities. And they're going to launch it, they're going to start withholding money, and they're just going to hope that the federal bureaucracy will provide them cover, that Nixon won't really know what's going on until they're deeply into enforcing the law.
而这最终就是他们决定的方式。他们决定启动一个名为“开放社区”的项目。他们打算启动它，打算开始扣留资金，并且只希望联邦官僚机构能为他们提供掩护，希望尼克松在他们深入执法之前不会真正知道发生了什么。
So under Romney, HUD started checking, were communities complying with the Fair Housing Act, and if not, withhold money. Use federal dollars as both carrot and stick.
因此在罗姆尼的领导下，HUD开始检查社区是否遵守《公平住房法》，如果不遵守，就扣留资金。将联邦资金作为“胡萝卜加大棒”。
Really, HUD could go after almost any community at that point, right, because almost every community was discriminating in some way in the way it was dealing with housing and development dollars. In Boston, there was-- they were trying to build some government housing, and Boston was blocking that housing, so that came to HUD's attention. And HUD says, OK, you either allow this housing to go in, or we're going to-- we're not going to give you this grant. And these cities were basically building highways, they were building infrastructure, almost entirely with federal dollars in some cases, so this was a pretty big deal. And remarkably, cities started to comply when they were threatened with these federal dollars.
实际上，HUD当时可以针对几乎任何社区，对吧？因为几乎每个社区在处理住房和开发资金方面都以某种方式进行歧视。在波士顿，他们试图建造一些政府住房，但波士顿阻止了这些住房，这引起了HUD的注意。HUD说：好了，你要么允许这些住房进来，要么我们就……我们就不给你这笔补助金。这些城市在某些情况下几乎完全是用联邦资金建设高速公路和基础设施的，所以这是一个相当大的交易。值得注意的是，当这些城市受到联邦资金威胁时，他们开始合规。
As Romney is moving ahead with his plan, having some initial successes, he gets a letter from Nixon's advisor John Ehrlichman, saying basically--
就在罗姆尼推动他的计划并取得一些初步成功时，他收到了一封尼克松顾问约翰·埃利希曼（John Ehrlichman）的信，基本意思是……
Uh, we're starting to hear about some program you have, but we haven't given any clearance. And Romney just brushes it off, and he's like, oh, we're just talking about it, we're not actually really doing anything yet. Of course he was. But, you know, it's a federal bureaucracy, and HUD was just one of many agencies, so--
“呃，我们开始听说你有什么项目了，但我们还没批准。”而罗姆尼直接把它打发了，他说：“哦，我们只是在讨论它，我们还没真正做什么。”当然，他已经在做了。但是，你知道，这是一个联邦官僚机构，HUD只是众多机构之一，所以……
So he just lies.
所以他就撒谎。
He-- yeah.
他……是的。
In order to keep moving ahead with this, and that works.
为了继续推进这件事，而且这确实起效了。
And it works--
而且这起效了……
For a while.
持续了一段时间。
Romney clearly had guile, but he couldn't keep his program secret forever. And he'd started something that couldn't last without the support of the White House. And the White House was hearing complaints about what he was doing. From Michigan, Romney's home state. Romney had tried to withhold money from a city called Warren, Michigan, because of discriminatory housing policies. Romney had had a previous run in with Warren as governor.
罗姆尼显然很有手段，但他不可能永远对项目保密。他启动的事情如果没有白宫的支持是无法持久的。而白宫当时听到了关于他在做什么的抱怨。来自密歇根州，罗姆尼的家乡。罗姆尼曾试图因为歧视性的住房政策扣留一个名为沃伦（Warren）的密歇根州城市的资金。罗姆尼担任州长时曾与沃伦有过交集。
Very, very segregated. When an interracial family had tried to move into a neighborhood, Romney had been forced as governor to send in the state police, because the neighbors raised such a ruckus and were threatening that family.
非常、非常严重的种族隔离。当一个跨种族家庭试图搬进一个社区时，罗姆尼作为州长被迫派出州警察，因为邻居们闹得不可开交，并威胁那个家庭。
Warren was one of the places white Detroiters had fled to after the riots.
沃伦是底特律白人骚乱后逃往的地方之一。
So these were people who felt very raw, who had intentionally moved to this community so that they would not have to live around black people, and they were very upset.
所以这些人感觉非常敏感，他们特意搬到这个社区就是为了不必和黑人住在一起，他们非常不满。
As HUD secretary, Romney made a tentative deal with Warren officials, and that might have been the end of it, but then the case got press. The Detroit News headline was "US picks Warren as prime target in move to integrate all suburbs." Residents of Warren and other suburbs were up in arms. Warren's mayor said the town would not be, quote, "a guinea pig for integration experiments." The White House told Romney to back off and give Warren the money.
作为HUD部长，罗姆尼与沃伦官员达成了初步协议，那本可以就此结束的，但案件被媒体曝光了。《底特律新闻》的头条是“美国将沃伦选为强制融合所有郊区的首要目标”。沃伦和其他郊区的居民愤怒了。沃伦市长说，该镇不会成为“融合实验的豚鼠”。白宫告诉罗姆尼收手，给沃伦资金。
When Nixon had appointed Romney, he praised his, quote, "missionary zeal." Now Nixon and his advisers were talking in memos behind the scenes about having, quote, "a serious Romney problem." When Romney tried to pressure Atlanta, a group of Nixon's Southern supporters met with the president. They'd been key to his election.
当尼克松任命罗姆尼时，他称赞了他的“传教士般的狂热”。现在尼克松和他的顾问们在幕后备忘录里谈论有一个“严重的罗姆尼问题”。当罗姆尼试图向亚特兰大施压时，一群尼克松的南方支持者会见了总统。他们是他当选的关键。
They tell him, you made promises to us. That's why we supported you. And now people are beginning to think of you as Mr. Integrator, which was an insult, apparently.
他们告诉他：“你对我们许下了承诺。这就是我们支持你的原因。现在人们开始把你视为‘融合先生’（Mr. Integrator）。”这显然是个侮辱。
And they told him, we in the South are motivated by race. And these are all in meeting notes from that meeting with Nixon, and they pressured him to do something to rein Romney in. And that's when he starts to freeze Romney out of the administration.
他们告诉他：“我们在南方是受种族情绪驱动的。”这些都在与尼克松会面的纪要里，他们施压让他采取行动来限制罗姆尼。也就是从那时起，他开始在政府内部边缘化罗姆尼。
Nixon stopped meeting with Romney. Not only were some of his supporters complaining to him, he also didn't agree with what Romney was doing. He sent an intermediary to Romney to tell him that his special skill set would now be most useful to the administration in Mexico as ambassador.
尼克松不再与罗姆尼会面。不仅是因为一些支持者向他抱怨，他也不认同罗姆尼的做法。他派了一个中间人去告诉罗姆尼，他特殊的技能组合现在作为大使去墨西哥对政府最有帮助。
Romney didn't want that. It's very clear from the unofficial resignation letter that Romney wrote Nixon that he knew he was being pushed out and that Nixon wanted a HUD secretary that was more to his political liking. He turned it down, and he resigned.
罗姆尼不想去。从罗姆尼写给尼克松的非正式辞职信中可以清楚地看出，他知道自己被排挤了，尼克松想要一个更符合他政治胃口的HUD部长。他拒绝了，并辞职了。
A new law is a battlefield. People and branches of government fight over interpretation and enforcement, and lack of precision in a law's wording can be turned to anyone's advantage. Romney had used the broadness of affirmatively furthering fair housing to push federal action. Nixon used the vagueness of those words to limit federal action.
新法律就是一个战场。政府的不同分支争论解释和执行，法律措辞的缺乏精确性可以被任何人利用。罗姆尼利用“积极进一步推进公平住房”的广泛性来推动联邦行动。尼克松利用这些话语的模糊性来限制联邦行动。
Nixon begins to gather his lawyers and staff to determine just how narrowly he can enforce the Fair Housing Act. And he sends out a staff to produce these memos for him. And when one of his staff members comes back and says, well, what Romney was doing was actually within the law, and I don't think we can ignore this mandate to be active in breaking down segregation, he's chastised for that, as kind of not being on board, and is told to go back in and rewrite a more narrow reading.
尼克松开始召集他的律师和幕僚，确定他能多狭隘地执行《公平住房法》。他派人写备忘录。当他的一名幕僚回来建议说：罗姆尼所做的实际上是在法律范围内的，我不认为我们可以忽视这项积极打破种族隔离的授权时，他受到了指责，被认为“立场不坚定”，并被要求回去重写一份更狭隘的解读。
In a private memo to his advisers, Nixon wrote, quote, "Even if I should become convinced, and I don't think it would be possible to convince me, that forced integration of education and housing was in the best interests of blacks and not too detrimental to whites, I could not possibly support it in good conscience."
在写给顾问的私人备忘录中，尼克松写道：“即使我被说服——我认为也不可能说服我——强制学校和住房融合符合黑人的最大利益，且对白人损害不大，我也绝不可能良心上支持它。”
He, I think-- it's easy to demonize him, but I think Nixon encapsulates that tension that has always been with us around issues of race in that we never put as much effort into undoing the harms as effort that we've put into creating them. And he believed that he was taking the more practical, moderate view, which is, of course legal segregation is wrong, and it's a good thing that we have gotten rid of that, but it's also wrong to disrupt people, to force upon people something that they don't want.
我想……妖魔化他很容易，但我认为尼克松概括了我们在种族问题上一直存在的紧张关系：我们从未像投入制造伤害那样投入精力去消除伤害。他认为自己采取了更实际、温和的立场，即：合法的种族隔离是错误的，消除它是件好事，但去干扰人们、强加给人们他们不想要的东西也是错误的。
President Nixon elaborated on his views in that memo to his advisers Ehrlichman and Haldeman, basically a long single-spaced typed letter.
尼克松总统在给他的顾问埃利希曼和霍尔德曼的备忘录中详细阐述了他的观点，基本上是一封长长的、单倍行距打印的信。
What was most chilling about that letter to me-- and this was-- he was doing all this-- it was an eyes only memo to his two most trusted advisers, this was not something that he talked about publicly-- and what he said was, "I realize that this position will lead us to a situation in which blacks will continue to live for the most part in black neighborhoods, and where there will be predominantly black schools, and predominantly white schools."
那封信让我觉得最不寒而栗的是——他做这一切时——那是一份仅供阅读的备忘录，给他最信任的两名顾问，这并不是他在公开场合谈论的事情——他说的是：“我意识到这种立场将导致黑人继续大部分生活在黑人社区，并将有以黑人为主的学校和以白人为主的学校。”
And you're reading this from the letter.
你是在读那封信的内容。
I'm reading directly from the letter. So he understands that what this means is that what-- the very issues that the civil rights laws were supposed to pass-- I mean address-- will go unaddressed, right. By taking this view, the schools will still be segregated and neighborhoods will still be segregated. And if you think about the way that we talk about these issues today, the argument is that yes, legal segregation was wrong, but policies that take race into account to address these issues are just as wrong.
我直接读那封信。所以他明白这意味着，民权法本应通过——我是说解决——的问题将得不到解决。采取这种观点，学校将依然隔离，社区也将依然隔离。如果你想想我们今天谈论这些问题的方式，论点是：是的，合法的种族隔离是错误的，但将种族纳入考虑以解决这些问题的政策同样是错误的。
So where has that left us? It's left us in a place where we no longer have segregation by law, but we still have segregation by fact, and this moderate view says that there's nothing we can or should do about it. And I think when you think about that logic, that's a logic that has held true really over the last 40 years.
那么这把我们留在了哪里？它把我们留在一个不再有法律上的种族隔离，但仍有事实上的种族隔离的地方，而这种温和观点说，我们对此无能为力，也不该做任何事。我认为当你考虑这种逻辑时，这是一种在过去40年里一直成立的逻辑。
The Fair Housing Act has been enforced unevenly by the federal government, to say the least, in the last four decades. A lot has depended on individual people or advocacy organizations bringing lawsuits under the act one at a time, or the Department of Justice bringing lawsuits. For the first 20 years of the law, HUD didn't even have the power to sue a landlord or company if HUD believed they were discriminating. HUD couldn't compel anyone to do anything. They could just mediate, like a sort of housing couples therapist.
在过去40年里，《公平住房法》一直被联邦政府断断续续地执行。这很大程度上取决于个人或倡导组织根据该法案逐一提起诉讼，或者司法部提起诉讼。在法律执行的前20年，如果HUD认为房东或公司存在歧视，HUD甚至没有权力起诉他们。HUD不能强迫任何人做任何事。他们只能调解，就像某种住房的夫妻治疗师一样。
And the part of the Fair Housing Act that was meant to address the big picture, to make sure zoning laws and local housing policies comply with the law, the mandate to affirmatively further fair housing, to actively fix the problem, that's been more or less in a coma since George Romney left, even though periodically people try to revive it by deciding on some new interpretation of what it means to affirmatively further fair housing. The Obama administration recently made a move to revive it. We'll see what happens with that.
而《公平住房法》中旨在从大局出发、确保分区法和地方住房政策符合法律、强制“积极进一步推进公平住房”、积极解决问题的那一部分，在乔治·罗姆尼离开后基本上就处于昏迷状态，尽管人们不时通过决定对“积极进一步”推进公平住房的新解释来试图复苏它。奥巴马政府最近采取了复苏它的举措。我们将看看接下来会发生什么。
So given this record of enforcement, where are we? Well, there's no question that black-white segregation has declined significantly overall in the United States. Specifically, some African Americans have left the highly segregated cities of the Northeast and the Midwest and migrated to less segregated Sun Belt cities. Also, relatively small numbers of African Americans who can afford it have moved into formerly all white or mostly white communities. What's left behind are concentrated areas that are usually poor and mostly African-American.
考虑到这种执法记录，我们现在处于什么位置？毫无疑问，美国黑白种族隔离的程度总体上已经显著下降了。具体来说，一些非裔美国人离开了东北部和中西部种族隔离严重的城市，迁徙到了种族隔离较轻的阳光地带城市。此外，少数负担得起的非裔美国人搬进了曾经全白人或白人为主的社区。留下来的是贫困且几乎全是黑人的集中区域。
But that can make it seem like segregation now is all about poverty rather than race, and it's not. The average African-American household making $75,000 a year or more, that family lives in a poorer neighborhood than the average white family making less than $40,000 a year. That is, a black family making twice as much money as a white family probably still lives in a poorer neighborhood. That's according to a study from Brown University. Racial segregation and not just people's income is key to understanding where people live and why, though I'm not sure we're facing the reality of that today.
但这可能会让人觉得现在的种族隔离完全是关于贫困而不是种族，其实不然。平均收入7.5万美元或以上的非裔美国人家庭，其居住的社区比平均收入不到4万美元的白人家庭还要贫穷。也就是说，一个收入是白人家庭两倍的黑人家庭，可能仍然生活在一个更穷的社区。这是根据布朗大学的一项研究得出的结论。种族隔离，而不仅仅是人们的收入，是理解人们住在哪里的关键，尽管我不确定我们今天是否在正视这个现实。
It's always a shock, you know.
这总是一个令人震惊的消息，你知道的。
This is L.B. again, the housing tester for the Fair Housing Justice Center who kept telling the super that his wife really liked the building.
这是L.B.，公平住房正义中心的住房测试员，他不断告诉管理员他妻子真的很喜欢那栋楼。
Especially, you know, it's 2013 now, and I could see that happening years and years and years ago, but it's still going on, and that's unfortunate.
特别是，现在已经是2013年了，我可以看到这种情况在多年前就发生了，但这仍然在持续，这很不幸。
You've lived in New York since the '70s. I mean, had you encountered discrimination just on your own, looking for apartments?
你从70年代起就住在纽约。我是说，你自己找公寓时遇到过歧视吗？
Not so much looking for apartments on my own, but in other areas of my life I've encountered that, but not so much looking for an apartment. At least not that I was aware of. You know, I've been told that things weren't available, but I just assumed that they weren't available.
我自己找公寓时遇到的不多，但在我生活的其他领域遇到过，但找公寓时遇到的不多。至少在我意识到的范围内是这样。你知道，有人告诉过我没房了，但我只是假设它们确实没房了。
The point of the Fair Housing Act is not that every black person in America has to have a white neighbor, and anything short of that means they're being discriminated against, but look at where we are 45 years later. Some states have no housing testers at all. They're basically on the honor system. In the places that do have it, most of the testing is done not by the government, but by advocacy organizations like the one L.B. works for. Which for New York City means its 8.3 million people are relying for most of their testing for compliance with the Fair Housing Act on a nonprofit organization and a group of actors hired part-time.
《公平住房法》的要点并不是美国每一个黑人都必须有一个白人邻居，否则就意味着他们受到了歧视。但看看45年后的今天，我们处在哪里。有些州根本没有任何住房测试员。它们基本上处于“诚信系统”下。在有测试的地区，大部分测试不是由政府完成的，而是由像L.B.工作的这类倡导组织完成的。这意味着对于纽约市的830万人口来说，他们对公平住房法合规性的测试，大部分依赖于一个非营利组织和一群兼职聘用的演员。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our program. Nikole Hannah-Jones' investigative series on the history and enforcement of the fair housing laws is at ProPublica's website, propublica.org.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作人之一。妮可·汉娜-琼斯关于住房公平法历史和执行的调查系列可以在ProPublica的网站propublica.org上找到。
Our program was produced today by our senior producer Julie Snyder, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Production help from Dana Chivvis. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
今天的节目由我们的高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）制作，参与制作的还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、美纪·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。制作协助来自达纳·奇维斯。塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。阿德里安娜·马蒂沃茨运营我们的网站。研究协助来自米歇尔·哈里斯和朱莉·比尔。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Thanks as always to Torey Malatia-- you know, This American Life was on the air for like, I don't know, eight months, something like that, when one day, as the guy running our home station WBEZ, Torey gave me a phone call.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《This American Life》由公共广播国际分发。一如既往地感谢托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）——你知道，《This American Life》刚播出大约八个月左右时，有一天，作为我们母台WBEZ站长的托里给我打了个电话。
Um, we're starting to hear about some program you have, but we haven't given any clearance.
“嗯，我们开始听说你有什么项目了，但我们还没批准。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《This American Life》的更多故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。